>> ♪ ♪
>> Tucker: LAST SPRING PRESIDENT
TRUMP WAS RIDICULED AND
DISMISSED AS A LUNATIC FOR
TWEETING OUT THAT THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION HAD WIRETAPPED
HIS CAMPAIGN BEFORE THE 2016
ELECTION.
THIS WAS DENOUNCED AS A LIE AND
DELUSION.
PRE-ELECTION ABUSES OF FISA THAT
ALLOWS THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH TO
ENCAGE IN THE SURVEILLANCE OF
CITIZENS AND WAS REAUTHORIZED BY
MEMO BE RELEASED.
THEY ARE JOINED IN THAT BY THE
ACLU.
ACLU
A CONGRESS WHO HAS SEEN THE MEMO
JOIN US TONIGHT.
YOU ARE BOUND BY LAW NOT TO
DIVULGE DETAILS OF THE MEMO.
GIVE US A SENSE OF YOUR REACTION
TO THE EXTEND YOU AND TELL US
WHY IT'S A BIG DEAL.
>> WITHIN THE LAST 2 HOURS, 63
OF MY REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES
JOINED ME IN SENDING A LETTER TO
THE INTELLIGENCE CHAIR MAN NUNES
TO HOLD A VOTE OF THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE TO
RELEASE THIS MEMO.
EVALUATE THE ALLEGATIONS AND
THE ACTIVITIES OF THE LAST
ADMINISTRATION, THE CRIMES I
INVESTIGATION IS BUILT ON A
FALSE PREMISE AND ROTTEN TO THE
CORE.
>> Tucker: THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES TWEETED MONTHS AGO
THAT HE BELIEVED HE WAS
SURVEILED DURING THE CAMPAIGN.
WILL THIS MEMO BOLTSTER THIS
POINT?
>> WELL TO RESPOND I AM DUTY
BOUND NOT TO DO.
THAT I CAN'T TALK ON TELEVISION
TONIGHT ABOUT THINGS WE
DISCUSSED IN THE PAST.
THIS MEMO NAMES, NAMES.
IT CONNECTS THE PLAYERS THAT
FOLKS ARE FAMILIAR CAN.
NAMES AND ORGANIZATIONS IN THE
NEWS.
IT'S NOTE WORTHY THAT EVERY
SINGLE DEMOCRAT ON THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE VOTED
AGAINST ALLOWING ME TO SEE THE
MEMO.
EVEN TODAY DEMOCRATS ARE
REFUSEING TO GO TO THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE ROOM AND,
VAIL THEMSELVES TO THE
INFORMATION IN THIS MEMO.
I WANT TO BLOW PAST THE RED
TAPE.
THE BEST DISEN FECTANT TO THE
CORRUPTION IN THIS MEMO IS THE
SUNSHINE OF TRANSPARENCY.
>> Tucker: YOU BELIEVE THIS MEMO
POINTS TO ILLEGAL ACTIVITY BY
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT BUT IT'S
ILLEGAL FOR YOU TO SAY WHAT IT
RIGHT NOW IT'S A TOP SECRET
DOCUMENT.
I THINK HEADS WILL ROLL AND
PEOPLE WILL BE FIRED AND SOME
MAY GO TO JAIL.
>> Tucker: TOP SECRET IS
DESIGNED FOR SELF-PRESERVATION.